[Música]
el acuerdo para suspender las patentes
de las vacunas antich audite propuesto
por india y sudáfrica en el año 2020
autoriza el uso sin consentimiento del
titular de los derechos de las patentes
necesarias para así producir y
suministrar esas dosis incluyendo
ingredientes y procesos se aplicará sólo
a los países en desarrollo aunque pida a
aquellos que estén en este grupo y sean
grandes productores de vacunas en caso
por ejemplo de china que asuman
voluntariamente un compromiso vinculante
de no acogerse a esta suspensión que se
aplicará durante cinco años a partir de
pues el día que se realizó este acuerdo
está suspensión trae consecuencias
económicas y la mayor pregunta es qué
pasará con las farmacéuticas ante este
acuerdo para ello entonces quiero
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado el
día el es amos josé garcía rojas él es
el presidente de la asociación española
de vacunología y máster en economía de
salud y gestión sanitaria y por supuesto
también como ya lo dijimos anteriormente
nos acompaña en esta mesa de trabajo
danielle hablando nuestra cronista de
economía daniela claro raúl es que es
bien importante porque las ceutí casas
dieron un salto muy grande entre entre
antes de la pandemia y lo que es ahora
de la pandemia en términos de ganancias
y de ingresos ya veremos las cifras
entonces así es aunque muchos también
dicen que esto ha llegado muy tarde amos
gracias nuevamente por acompañarnos en
esta mesa de trabajo en directo américa
de francioni 4 y para que sigamos
allanar el camino a hacer un contexto
que representa económicamente hablando
para los desarrolladores de las vacunas
esta liberación de las patentes
bueno yo soy le conoce economista me
cuesta trabajo tratar de situarme la
llegada de la economía soy
fundamentalmente un con green de
lanzarlo pero sigue para no puede ser un
elemento que crea algún tipo de
distorsión siguiente en la situación
actual el gran tema antes sobre la
liberalización de las patentes siempre
estamos presentes desde el estallido de
la pandemia fundamentalmente por la
disparidad en la distribución del
producto entre los países ricos de los
países pobres la ong se diseñó junto a
otras organizaciones como la fundación
bill y melinda gates
en el proyecto como kóvacs que sin
embargo que quería como finalidad que
era una central y común de compra de
vacuna frente a la pandemia de manera
que se garantizará la equidad de
distribución del producto a tono países
del mundo sin embargo cuando empezaron a
producir se comparten los laboratorios
la vacuna 30 era algo vil pues los
países ricos empezaron a encontrar las
unidades de colores y hoy
desgraciadamente mientras que en los
países ricos se están planteando debates
con una convención de la administración
de la cuarta dosis en varios de los
países en desarrollo los
primeros
bueno señor amos que implica entonces
hombre voy a empezar por darles unas
cifras y es que en fin se duplicó sus
ganancias en 2021 moderna logró su
primer año de beneficios 12 mil millones
de dólares ganó en 2021 bayón entre las
tres variantes facer y modernas tuvieron
se estima ingresos por 60 mil millones
de dólares esto yo sé que es muy buena
muy económico pero también la gente del
común piensa bueno pero porque si están
teniendo tantos beneficios porque no
liberar entonces esas patentes y
servirle al resto de la humanidad como
como piensa una empresa que hace esto
estas vacunas de cara a estas
situaciones
sino desde luego es evidente que la
situación excepcional que nos ha traído
las pandemias posibilitado en los
productores del gran instrumento que nos
ha podido modular el impacto dramático
terrible que tenía la pandemia en el
vinculado a los fallecimientos a los
casos graves
los productos desde esta vacuna que son
las vacunas pues han tenido un
crecimiento desmesurado en su fuente de
ingresos y lamentablemente
lamentablemente a este producto no
llegue a todos los países del mundo por
lo tanto la liberalización de las
patentes
sería un elemento de indudablemente que
situar en el contexto del debate el
debate en el contexto de más de una
situación excepcional como es la
expansión terrible del sar con dos que
en el desarrollo de un proceso pandémico
que ha revolucionado todo el mundo en
los últimos dos años uno dato tiene que
estar en el debate tiene aspectos
positivos tiene mucho puedes dar un
aspecto negativo también pero
evidentemente hay que introducir lo que
potencia
como que la vacuna llegue al brazo de
todas las personas del mundo que las
necesita vamos también le quería
preguntar si con esta liberación de las
patentes implicaría de alguna manera
eliminar digamos los incentivos para la
producción de los fármacos para futuras
vacunas y futuras pandemias como
tomarían eso también en las
farmacéuticas ante toda esa liberación
si no es un riesgo evidente son un
riesgo evidente
puede a toda la complementó que te quite
incentivos a la hora de desarrollar
proyectos de investigación proyectos de
desarrollo de vacunas en los
laboratorios los productos desde la
misma
y eso es así y algunos elementos que hay
que tener siempre también presente a la
hora de establecer algún tipo de
intervención al respecto yo creo que lo
que hay que llegar esas puntos
intermedios puntos de equilibrio que
posibiliten que todos los sectores
implicados con estas racionales 20 a
mundos justos algunos tendrán que perder
algo que significará que otros que son
los demás no necesitan lograr por lo
tanto en este punto de equilibrio lo que
hay que procurar es garantizar lo que lo
que son unos beneficios objetivos por
parte de los productores de las vacunas
que han desarrollado un proceso de
inversión importante pero al mismo
tiempo que estos beneficios no son 'las
en la posibilidad de que las vacunas
lleguen a los países en vías de
desarrollo
señalamos mirando un poco en
retrospectiva no deberían haber
desarrollado antes investigaciones o de
cara al futuro también deberían
desarrollar antes de investigaciones que
no los obligue a después o cuando llegue
una pandemia a actuar en ese momento y
que tengan que recibir inclusive
recursos públicos que fueron bastante
recursos públicos para hacer estos
desarrollos y adelantarse a esas
situaciones
sí muchísimas de las vacunas frente a
esta ley entre otras cosas porque lo
de las autoridades públicas han estado
produciendo un ha estado desarrollando
un gran proceso de inversión de
donación de dinero en ese proceso de
investigación de derecho evidentemente
lo que pasa es que el sant con todo
surge en un contexto del que nadie podía
prever el balance de este problema yo
creo que ya una situación que yo hace
difícil que podamos tener claro crear
una infraestructura de frente a un
microorganismo que no sabemos
exactamente cómo va cómo va a
desarrollarse yo no pero fundamental es
ser consciente en estos momentos de que
problemas de este tipo vamos a seguir
teniendo de futuro vamos a seguir
teniendo y los asentamientos por tres
cuestiones fundamentales en primer lugar
porque estamos en un proceso de
calentamiento global cuyos síntomas es
el cambio climático que está produciendo
un cambio
díaz
microorganismo porque estamos ante un
aumento desmesurado de las diferencias
entre países ricos y países pobres y en
los países pobres este incremento de la
pobreza
significa una posibilidad clara de
acción de los problemas
transmisibles en forma pandémica del mar
y porque además tenemos que ser
conscientes de que ese concepto clave se
está poniendo permanentemente sobre una
mesa peruana una salud humana salud
ambiental salud animal tiene que ser
asumido por parte de todo de todos los
sistemas sanitarios del mundo la
necesidad de reforzar la salud humana
pero que va a llegar a la mente a un
reforzamiento a la salud animal y de la
salud ambiental y eso son las mejores
vacunas que puede desarrollando
para evitar o para tener la capacidad de
evitar problemas tan técnicos en el
futuro y para también evitar el que
tengamos que
y vernos desde alguna manera en fuera de
juego con la llegada de un problema
estético